welcome to the MCU family what a panel
because we have Natalie Portman as
female Thor we have Angelina Jolie we
have Rachel vice I mean what does it
mean to be the futures female seems to
be and it seems to be that Marvel have
really focused on getting very
interesting roles made for women
powerful interesting complicated women
so it's very exciting be a powerful
interesting complicated winning women
how would you describe milena is that am
I saying that right milena
how would you describe her she is she's
been cycled through the Red Room Widow
program five times so she's pretty
highly skilled trained spy assassin he's
also pretty interested in science so is
there a possibility we will see you
fighting head-to-head with Natasha
Romanoff I say who in your life is the
most excited that you're joining the MCU
who is the most excited my my best
friend's son Frankie who is kind of
beside himself yeah he wants to visit
the fat so I said just let me just get a
few weeks in and then I'll bring you but
Frankie is a bonafide a marvel just just
obsessed obsessed
you'll probably be getting a lot of set
requests
you